wir blicken auf eisenhüttenstadt in
brandenburg dieser ort ist zurzeit
schauplatz eines europäischen konflikts
wenn hier sammeln sich moment
flüchtlinge aus ganz europa und der
grund streit mit dem belarussischen
präsidenten alexander lukaschenko
sind besorgniserregende entwicklungen
immer mehr flüchtlinge und migranten
kommen nach deutschland insbesondere aus
zwei ländern und zwar aus griechenland
obwohl die flüchtlinge dort bereits
schutzanspruch haben und aus belarus von
dort bringt diktator alexander
lukaschenko migranten aus afghanistan
und dem irak an die polnische grenze um
sie in die eu zu schicken den
vergangenen drei monaten hat sich die
zahl der flüchtlinge die über polen in
das erstaufnahmelager in
eisenhüttenstadt ankommen mehr als
verdoppelt
es sind besorgniserregende entwicklungen
immer mehr flüchtlinge und migranten
kommen nach deutschland insbesondere aus
zwei ländern griechenland obwohl die
flüchtlinge dort bereits schutzanspruch
haben und belarus von dort bringt
diktator alexander lukaschenko migranten
aus afghanistan und dem irak an die
polnische grenze um sie in die eu zu
schicken in den vergangenen drei monaten
hat sich die zahl der flüchtlinge die
über polen in das erstaufnahmelager in
eisenhüttenstadt ankommen mehr als
verdoppelt noch dramatischer die zahlen
der flüchtlinge die über griechenland
kommen
27.500 asylsuchende haben laut behörden
in diesem jahr schon in deutschland
einen asylantrag gestellt der skandal
dabei die flüchtlinge kommen nach
deutschland obwohl sie bereits in einem
sicheren land waren in griechenland
hatten sie schutzanspruch und trotzdem
darf sie deutschland nicht
zurückschicken der grund zwei ober
gerichte urteilten unterbringung und
verpflegung seien dort menschenunwürdig
also zwei länder griechenland und
belarus im moment im blickpunkt
lukaschenko der präsident der diktator
von belarus hat der eu offen gedroht wir
haben migranten und drogen aufgehalten
jetzt müsst ihr sie
er war von sagt er
und wir schalten jetzt zu unserem und
kollegen michael sauerbier der in
eisenhüttenstadt steht michael
vielleicht maximal beschreiben was hat
sich jetzt verändert dort vor ort
müsse in klaren worten zu sagen hier in
eisenhüttenstadt in der erst
aufnahmeeinrichtung des landes
brandenburg hat sich alles verändert bis
zum mai kam hier ungefähr 500
flüchtlinge monatlich an im juli stieg
die zahl dann erstmals im august
drastisch und jetzt zu zwei dritteln der
september hat sie sich gegenüber dem
august erneut verdoppelt das hat den
grund den er eben schon geschildert habe
brandenburg ist die
das bundesland an dem der
flüchtlingsstrom kommt den uns der
belarussische diktator lukaschenko nun
in der eu schickt
was sich hier zunächst verändert hat
kann man rund um mich herum sehen vor
allem im hintergrund eigentlich ist
diese erstaufnahmeeinrichtung mit ihren
1100 plätzen ein steinernes
modernisiertes ehemaliges
kasernengebäude mit festen gebäuden nun
mussten dutzendweise container dazu
gebaut werden in den letzten wochen und
seit gestern und das sieht man mir im
hintergrund werden auch noch zelte
aufgestellt war die zahl der flüchtlinge
täglich wächst ich will euch dass man
den zahlen sagen am montag zb kamen 40
leute über die polnische grenze aus
weißrussland am dienstag waren es 69
gestern waren es schon 80 das heißt die
erstaufnahmeeinrichtung platzt aus allen
nähten
jeder der hier ankommt muss zunächst für
drei bis vier tage in einer aufnahme
quarantäne danach werden die leute
erkennungsdienstlich behandelt mal
schauen ob man hier vielleicht schon
kennt ob sie vielleicht noch eine
reststrafe abzusitzen haben danach
werden sie medizinisch untersucht etwa
auf tuberkulose und selbstverständlich
auch auf kroner und die zahl der korona
viele der flüchtlinge die hier rüber
kommen ist nicht ganz unberechtigt bis
zu zehn prozent
für die eben mussten nochmal spezielle
quarantäne container gebaut werden wir
sind hier am anschlag wir sind an der
grenze der aufnahmefähigkeit sagte mir
der chef des erstaufnahmelager olaf
janßen und
sehr interessant ist die art und weise
wie denn die flüchtlinge und zwar
vorwiegend aus dem nahen osten über
diese neue route über minsk in
weißrussland nach deutschland kommen wir
haben dazu gesprochen mit einem jungen
mann einem studenten aus dem
bürgerkriegsland yemen der zunächst vier
jahre in china maschinenbau studiert
hatte und dann mit beginn der kroner
welle wie alle ausländischen studenten
china verlassen musste
das hören wir uns mal an
jeden tag versuche ich an zu kommen ich
will nach belarus ich werde aber immer
nach polen gebracht und von dort
wiederum will mich dann die polnische
polizei nach belarus schicken ich will
ja auch nach minsk aber die bälle
russische polizei lässt mich nicht ins
land die wollen dass ich in polen
bleiben ich darf also nicht zurück nach
belarus ich liebe wie ein tier zwölf
tage habe ich nichts kein internet keine
sim karte weil die polnische polizei
meine sim karte weggenommen hat ich habe
keinen platz zu bleiben ich kann nicht
mal meine freunde anrufen
habe ich keine ahnung wo ich bin am
morgen bin ich in belarus und dann
schicken sie mich nach polen und am
nächsten morgen nimmt mich dann die
polnische polizei mit und schickt mich
wieder zurück nach belarus und dann
wieder zurück und wieder hin und wieder
zurück
ja
wie hast du ihn erlebt
ich habe ihn geliebt als einen menschen
der vor wenigen tagen noch dramatisches
durchgemacht hat er hat uns erzählt dass
ihr nachdem er erfahren hat unter
scheint weißrussland regelrecht
propaganda in der welt zu machen nachdem
er also aus sozialen medien erfahren hat
dass man über weißrussland ganz einfach
nach deutschland kommen kann hat er
einen flug genommen von malaysia wo er
sich aufhielt also quasi einmal quer
durch asien nach europa und ist dann
direkt von der weißrussischen polizei
quasi vom flughafen bis drei kilometer
vor die polnische grenze gebracht worden
und dann haben sie ihm gezeigt da kannst
du rüber da ist der goldene westen und
das hat er dann unfassbare zwölf mal
versucht wurde immer wieder von
polnischer polizei aufgegriffen und
zurückgeschickt bis es ihnen gelungen
ist nach polen und dort mit einem taxi
in dem er mit fünf anderen saß also mit
einem schleuser direkt bis an die
deutsche grenze und hier ist er dann zu
fuß rüber gekommen und von der polizei
aufgegriffen worden das sind vorfälle
die es jetzt mehrfach tägliche zu
beobachten gibt man sieht im gesamten
grenzgebiet polizei und bundespolizei
autos streifen an den grenzübergängen an
den landstraßen im hinterland und da
werden dann gleich gruppenweise
flüchtlinge aufgegriffen und eben hier
in die erste aufnahme einrichtungen
gebracht interessant ist das was der
student uns erzählt hat jetzt mal aus
der großen perspektive was passiert ihr
der hintergrund ist dass im mai wie wir
noch wissen lukaschenka ein flugzeug
eine ryanair-maschine von athen nach
litauen entführt hat um einen
regime-gegner einem blogger zu verhaften
der an bord der maschine war daraufhin
hat die eu nach diesem unfassbaren
vorfall dieser staatlichen
flugzeugentführungen
sanktionen verhängt und weißrussland
versucht diese
und weißrussland versucht diese
sanktionen nun wieder weg zu kriegen
indem sie uns quasi diese
flüchtlingswelle bescheren die wir hier
besichtigen können
[Musik]